hey guys and welcome back to steampunks
2.0 a new and improved edition you'll
probably notice we have a new set behind
us new graphics but I'll say one call us
and we'll call it a table full of our
junk look I mean that's a PC get there
so you guys this is a PC show and we
were talking about PC game
recommendations each week we're still
gonna be doing that but we'd also like
to pile on everything that interests us
in the PC world from the topics that are
making waves to just the games and
things you probably want to know about
yep so this week saw the release of The
Walking Dead the final season which is
obviously the final season in Telltale's
long-running series sort of the the the
title that kicked off this new wave of
adventure games that's what we're gonna
be talking about today
when Walking Dead Season 1 came out it
kind of vag portrayed a new way of
showing an adventure and that was a more
immersive cinematic experience which
took a lot of agency away from you that
got you way more invested in the
characters and the narrative and all the
choices and consequences yeah that come
with those choices it's interesting
because I mean you and I played a lot of
classic point-and-click sort of
adventure games in our youth and there's
a lot of differences between that in the
telltale formula including I mean yes
you do lose agency because telltale
likes to take you down the garden path
of its story but at the same time the
choose-your-own-adventure element is
something that's quite modern when we
used to play adventure games and you
guys probably as well back in the 90s
early 2000s you were being shown a story
that they wanted to show you you didn't
really have the opportunity to decide
which characters lived or died or if you
wanted your character to be a dick or a
hero they just were what they were so I
think that's an interesting evolution
yeah it was more focused on the puzzles
and the kind of wacky universes that
these guys created so like I played a
lot of American solid mentor games
that's ER and LucasArts you play a lot
of European one yeah which are somehow
more difficult I would say so one of the
things we were talking about and there
are very famous examples of this Gabriel
Knight for one and longest journey and
still life also have great examples very
difficult puzzles kind of were landmarks
of old-school adventure games and that's
so
not really a thing with the tell-tale
formula that's right and so the question
is like did The Walking Dead like kill
what the adventure game was because if
enchi games went away for a long time
but it's very easy to forget that
telltale actually started off doing
puzzles as well like I'm a telltale fan
from a long way back starting off when
they revised him and Max and revived
Monkey Island and they had a focus on
puzzles and the puzzling element but
with the success of The Walking Dead
they saw that this could be really great
it could get a lot of sort of people
back into adventure games people who
probably didn't play a lot of games in
general to sort of be invested in this
sort of interactive narrative and it was
really successful for them you know you
and I both played a ton of telltale
Avenger games I kind of fell off them
when the game of Thrones and tells about
when they started like pulling in these
big-name franchises like the universal
franchises like up back in the future
and Jurassic Park at Minecraft and
Marvel where Batman they have DC and now
they have a partnership with Netflix
which really suits that kind of model
they've gone in their own completely
unique direction yeah and it's easier to
sort of think that okay well this is
what adventure games are now but that's
really not the case is it yeah I mean
there's still tons of other things
around foreigner fans of classic
point-and-click adventures there's a
company that web earth a pretty big fan
of fold watch at our games who just
brought out a new game called unev out
within the last month and it's pretty
fantastic works with some new elements
that you wouldn't have seen in old point
and click games like you build a party
that you can take with you um you have
several characters and you choose your
own protagonist I guess the big point
here is that you can still have an
adventure game that focuses on choice
and consequence and strong characters
like an avowed does but still have the
puzzling element yeah now uh Nevada is I
would personally say it's a bit easier
than the other sort of wedge Atty games
like residents Jim NAIRU Tecna Babylon
all those kind of a really really great
games that you should check out if you
like adventure games you can have the
best of both worlds you can have great
stories and characters and you have
puzzling on closer inspection there is a
small crack in the wall here the hand of
I think another really good example of
that and talking about European
adventure games is the longest journey
series now they started as
point-and-click moving through the world
as you'd expect from any game I think it
came around around 1999 and then it
morphed into a 3d adventure game still
the same strong characters really
fascinating narrative and the puzzling
elements although to be fair I do think
they've been scaled back from the kind
of puzzles that would have you sticking
around for days on end it's just not
knowing what to do but all the threads
that were so attractive to fans of the
original game was still there for the
second game and during full chapters
which came out just a couple of years
ago and that leads on to I think what
the appeal of telltale adventure games
is is when you pick up that game whether
you're playing it as an entire series
that takes your turn at ten hours or two
to three hours a month when they come
out you know you're gonna get through
that experience right it's not gonna
trip you up and given how many games are
coming out now that's probably something
that appeals to people absolutely I mean
it's it's really frustrating when you
hit a roadblock and in adventure game
like you know like oh the old leukocyte
stuff or thimble we'd park or something
like that yeah and then you kind of just
sort of bounce off it and tell-tell
really avoids that yeah but at the cost
of sort of taking away a lot of the
exploration elements a lot of the
interactivity which is fine and
obviously the final season of The
Walking Dead brings back some more
interactive elements in terms of the
combat and what you can do with
Clementine but it's also important not
to forget the genre of walking
simulators too so things like gone home
and obviously games like fire watch
which the directors of the first season
of The Walking Dead went on to create
yeah which is an adventure game style
experience that still lets you have the
interactive component of player driven
exploration which can be a huge part and
making me feel invested in that carbon
in that world yeah they're not like
really hardcore puzzle game sort of
elements but just the mere fact that you
dictate where you're going your own pace
and what you're looking at and what your
character is looking at makes that
experience your own and kind of makes it
feel more than you're just sitting and
watching a movie unfolding yeah I think
what I like so much about games like
fire watching gone home is that they're
really good examples of how the
adventure gaming genre is evolving into
more interesting places I mean
was once upon a time the reason we had
point and click games is because that's
what technology allowed so it's really
interesting to see this medium which I
do think is so extraordinarily good at
telling stories moving into these
different places and as we've said it
doesn't mean that the classic styles
need to go away I also want to give a
special shout to the Tacoma which has an
element of sort of interacting with the
story that I found super engaging in the
fact that you could experience these
sort of echoes of stuff that happened in
the past and sort of rewind them and
like possible with them and sort of
follow up follow different characters as
they sort of went through the spaces
easier to see what little stories
unfolding in different corners there
that yes very much
that's a great game and speaking of
rewinding and also having great
character life is strange is also doing
a wonderful job at that a game that I
can't believe that they were able to
adopt some of the limelight of telltale
really dominating that space when they
did but just showed that they had really
interesting stories to tell and just
like a real love for their characters
which I think underpins all of these
adventure game experiences no matter
what format they're being told in or how
long they take or how difficult they are
I have to admit I never really got into
the life this strange show is but I did
play the awesome Adventures of Captain
Spirit which is free on Steam if you
want to check that out and I was really
surprised by the sort of sandbox
exploration elements of that game too
because it still had to pick up this
item and use another item but still told
a story that sort of continued on no
matter what you did you can spend the
time playing with toys as Chris or you
could do like your superhero missions so
you could have objectives as well or you
could just you know wander out and sort
of pick up load trinkets and sort of
explore the world and sort of what the
backstory of Chris and his dad were all
without sort of sacrificing the pace of
what eventually happens in that overall
narrative turn answer the question do
the walking dead kill adventure games no
it really didn't there are still a lot
of really great adventure games tell
experiences that are very different to
the telltale model so don't think of
adventure games as just being an
interactive narrative these days
adventure games can be many different
things that can be like the old-school
thing it can be a new thing it could be
a number of different things but do let
us know what kind of adventure games you
guys like to play if indeed you're a fan
of adventure
and what you see the future of adventure
games being Oh tell us why you don't
like adventure games that's that's also
very valid and tell us anything you want
to see us chat about in the PC realm
what's got you interested and we'll be
back with another episode next week so
leave your comments
[Music]